on regarde dans les chambres si
effectivement il y en a pas un qui
détendent voilà pas de traces de
portable mais une belle surprise
de me le dire
[Musique]
il voulait sortir des plateaux prendre
l'air tâter le terrain
ils ne vont pas être déçus
Carole Rousseau et Benjamin Castaldi
partent à la rencontre d'hommes et de
femmes ordinaires au métier
extraordinaire
[Musique]
mes yeux à 20 km à l'ouest de Lyon
immersion immédiate dans une école pas
comme les autres ici on offre une
deuxième chance à des jeunes de 18 à 25
ans qui ont décroché en France il serait
près d'un million sans emploi sans
formation et sans repère
huit mois c'est le temps qu'ils auront
pour réapprendre les rudiments du vivre
ensemble et trouver un emploi
au programme
maths français entretien d'embauche
permis de conduire le tout dans un cadre
quasi militaire
créé en 2005 suite aux émeutes en
banlieue l'établissement public
d'insertion de la défense fête cette
année ses 10 ans plus de 28 000 jeunes
sont déjà passés par ces centres
d'insertion professionnelle et sociale
dit palmo élève non on dit pas le mot
école non plus j'imagine non
je vais suivre Ericsson et Marina ils
sont ici depuis six mois et se battent
pour surmonter leurs difficultés
ces jeunes luttent pour se faire une
place dans le monde des adultes
je vais partager leurs épreuves c'est
pas grave
leur moment de joie
[Rires]
pendant une semaine
à disposition dans les 18 centres de
Lépide la journée commence de la même
manière au même moment par le
rassemblement sous les drapeaux à 7h45
Laurent connaît parfaitement ce rituel
qui arithmé toute sa vie de légionnaires
devenu moniteur il entend bien faire
comprendre la portée de ce moment
symbolique à ces jeunes recrues
à respecter c'est extrêmement important
de la journée où honnêtement on
plaisante pas là c'est du sérieux
recteur prend lui aussi cette cérémonie
très au sérieux ancienne officier de
l'armée de terre il a mis des
générations de soldats au garde-à-vous
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui ce sont des
grands ados cabossés par la vie qu'il
doit remettre en état de marche
marina kleind et Ericsson Gomez
partagent la même section le compte à
rebours a déjà commencé il ne leur reste
que deux mois pour se préparer au monde
extérieur après ils seront de nouveau
livrés à eux-mêmes
[Musique]
contre nous de la tirelire mais ton
assemble
marseillaise uniforme garde à vous pas
de doute c'est bien le ministère de la
Défense qui a eu l'idée de ses centres
d'insertion mais ici on ne réinvente pas
le service militaire les jeunes on les
prépare à se battre pour se faire une
place dans la vie active ici on leur
enseigne la confiance en soi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
8h les élèves ont plutôt les volontaires
comme on les appelle ici se dirigent en
Cancer vers leur salle de cours
[Musique]
les R2 sur une colonne s'il vous plaît
oui marine n'est pas un ancien militaire
dans sa vie d'avant il a dirigé
plusieurs établissements de formation
professionnelle il a été l'un des
premiers à croire dans cette école d'un
nouveau genre une colonne
pour le plaisir d'accompagner ces jeunes
déboussolés il est redevenu simple
professeur
[Musique]
avant de vous asseoir on va peut-être
modifier un petit peu la salle on va
faire une étoile si on est d'accord
pendant un instant j'ai l'impression de
retourner au collège mais les méthodes
de Louis-Marie vont vite me faire
oublier cette sensation
pouvez vous asseoir merci ici on ne se
remet pas seulement à niveau en français
et en maths on apprend aussi à mieux se
connaître à exprimer ses sentiments avec
des mots
quels sont les cinq gardiens qui sont en
vous ces cinq je dirais cinq traits de
personnalité vous avez déjà monsieur
Gomez vous ça suffit et encore
le bouffon l'enfant qui est en vous
c'est lequel aujourd'hui à l'heure où
nous parlons a le plus important vous me
les classes
pour vous maintenant
je fais des devoirs
une activité
vous n'êtes pas de devoirs
si vous voulez dormir vous pouvez dormir
et comme je sais que ça vous intéresse
oui mais ça me fait rire s'il vous plaît
demain matin vous allez à un entretien
d'embauche quel est le garde l'ange
gardien que vous allez mettre en avant
de presque efficace pourquoi
la motivation
l'envie Loïc ça vient
il y a du forfait
bien on peut faire une petite mise en
commun le guerrier oui enfin
j'ai mis le guerrier
l'enfant
il se voit tous en guerrier comme si la
vie n'était qu'une suite de coup
apprendre et à donner bouffon j'ai mis
humour
est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
êtes entouré d'humour ou c'est vous qui
est à l'origine de l'humour
vous ne vous prenez pas au sérieux non
je me prends pas j'espère ne pas me
prendre au sérieux j'aimerais qu'on
fasse rire et j'essaye de faire rire
aussi le témoin numéro 8 c'est moi
de la vie d'être à l'équipe avec vous de
faire ce que mon métier ça j'aime désolé
par contre le bouffon je mettrais bien
en deuxième parce que quand vous savez
nous travaillons sérieusement mais je ne
suis pas sérieux parce que je trouve que
la vie est trop dure pour ne pas la
gérer la croquer tous les jours de
profiter de tous les bons moments que je
peux avoir même dans la difficulté quand
vous allez vers l'emploi effectivement
c'est celui-ci à qui on fait appel je
l'aurai ce poste je me battrai je suis
le meilleur et quand il pose la question
toute la subtilité du cours de Louis
Marie amener doucement ces jeunes à
prendre conscience du combat qui
s'annonce pour trouver un travail mais
sans jamais leur faire la leçon quand
vous passez de l'adolescence à l'adulte
en devenir ben effectivement il faut
s'éloigner de l'enfant mais on peut
toujours garder un cœur d'enfant
jusqu'à ma mort
et qu'est-ce que ça vous fait que je
sois un enfant
oui et puis
si tu as pas mal
éprouver de la joie en classe une
victoire pour Louis Marie car pour ces
jeunes l'école n'a souvent été qu'un
cauchemar une fois et quel est le mot de
trois lettres que je vous interdit
commence par un N
en venant monsieur je suis
tous ces mots là qui vous ont mis en
situation difficile dans les
établissements vous étiez avant vous
étiez pas plus en difficulté que les
autres mais le système ne vous convenait
pas et après on vous a catalogué comme
étant un élève nul et après excusez-moi
du peu vous l'avez entretenu
Mademoiselle Monsieur vous pouvez
enlever la méthode de Louis-Marie c'est
un concentré d'épide pour remotiver ces
jeunes il faut faire table rase du passé
je trouve que vous nous oubliez souvent
non mais faites attention vous savez
très bien que théoriquement je devrais
le confisquer
[Rires]
vous vous en sortez bien allez vous
témoins
mais j'accepte vos excuses alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait là on a fait un
médiation culturelle c'est un atelier
l'atelier c'était pas un cours non je ne
fais jamais voilà pour tout à l'heure
non on dit pas le mot école non plus
j'imagine non on fait jamais référence à
ce qui a pu être pour nous essayons
d'éviter tous les mots qui ont une
connotation négative à leur égard nous
sommes là pour les faire réussir donc
pour moi élève classe cours français
même le français n'est pas des fois je
mets expression culture générale ou
dépoussiérage de cerveau j'utilise plein
de petits mots différents que toutes ces
mots qui les rappellent ce qu'ils
avaient souffrir en fait j'ai vu une
jeune fille moi qui quand elle venait
aux ateliers mathématiques elle était en
pleurs
puis un bon matin nous allons dû en
savoir pourquoi pouf essayez elle a
décidé de réussir ça marche donc il faut
arriver à provoquer le déclic et c'est
là qu'il faut étudier de tous les
stratèges possibles pour qu'il puisse
prendre goût et s'approprie la matière
en tout cas
ici tout ne se joue pas devant un
tableau il y a aussi les ateliers
d'expression karaoké maquettisme photos
des cours pratiques où l'on apprend sans
s'en rendre compte la méthode la rigueur
et la discipline comme ici en cuisine
donc monsieur Gomez et Rocha vous allez
être avec Carole Rousseau et au fourneau
c'est Chloé une ancienne gendarme qui
donne le ton vous aussi monsieur chrono
il y a un miroir
ça marche
vous êtes magnifique
même si tout se déroule dans la bonne
humeur on n'est pas vraiment là pour
rigoler
[Musique]
à cuisiner respecter les règles
d'hygiène maîtriser les calculs simples
et les unités de mesure
soyez précis on peut en mettre bien des
choses dans une simple recette de
pâtisserie lyonnaise pas mal d'avoir une
assistante non vous en pensez quoi
vous inquiétez pas je dirais que c'est
de ma faute
[Musique]
jamais les mains vides allez hop non
vous terminez votre pâte et après vous
goûtez oh on arrête de s'éparpiller là
on peut terminer les choses que
convenablement
ce soir le dessert sera fait maison en
deux heures nous avons sorti 400 bunes
on a réussi encore une fois à sortir les
desserts en temps et en heure donc bah
allez-y vous pouvez désormais déguster
pour madame
[Rires]
entre leur décrochage à l'école et leur
prise en main dans ses centres il s'est
passé plusieurs années ils ont enchaîné
galère échecs et frustration quand ils
arrivent ici ils sont incapables de se
projeter dans l'avenir ils n'ont
confiance ni en eux ni en la République
[Musique]
dans le département il y a plusieurs
communes
et l'ensemble de certaines communes
forme des cantons
Daniel a passé 26 ans sous les drapeaux
il aimerait bien transmettre à ses
jeunes recrues son engagement au service
du pays sa fibre citoyenne
qui possèdent leurs cartes d'électeurs
jamais
si je vais voter ça va pas changer grand
chose ça sera toujours pareil donc ça
sert à rien
[Musique]
nous promet des trucs des choses ils le
font pas comme les changements c'est
maintenant qu'on a jamais on n'a jamais
vu du changement à quoi sert
où nous sommes
la question
mais ça mais ça c'est venu les pitres
comme ça parce que les gens n'allaient
pas voter ils restaient dans leur coin
et puis il y a quelqu'un en cachette qui
a dit ben on va créer des pides parce
qu'il y a des jeunes en difficulté
et vous vous posez pas la question de
savoir comment est né cet établissement
qui paye pourquoi vous êtes ici alors
moi je peux entendre que en effet
parfois il y en a qui mettent les jeunes
de côté mais c'est pas le cas pour tout
faut pas généraliser on m'a jamais
appelé par exemple moi j'appelle
j'appelle j'appelle et après une fois
que j'appelle la personne elle me répond
non on vous prend pas parce que il y
avait un tel comme ça en Afrique
quelqu'un d'autre alors qu'on vous a on
m'a on m'a promis de prendre la place
c'est ce place là moi je veux me sentir
comment
demain vous allez partir de lipides tout
le monde va pas vous ouvrir ses bras
pour dire venez travailler chez moi ça
je le sais par contre par contre vous
devez avoir des attitudes pour aller
chercher le travail
c'est pas parce qu'on vous a dit une
seule fois ben non que vous devez
baisser les bras et c'est vrai que vous
allez essuyer des échecs il faut se
remettre parfois aussi en question se
dire pourquoi ça a pas marché pourquoi
la personne aussi également un moment
donné elle a décidé de pas vous appeler
c'est pas ça parce que il dit ouais et
après il vous dit non qui a plus
d'expérience que vous c'est vrai et ça
arrivera encore monsieur moi dit ça
arrivera hélas il ne teste pas il
pourrait nous dire bah on vous prend on
essaye et si ça va on continue tout le
monde n'a pas de l'expérience et il veut
justement avoir un début de d'expérience
mademoiselle il faut aller les chercher
elles vont pas venir toute seule comme
ça et que ça va tomber du ciel il faut
se battre et vous avez raison monsieur
ça n'est quand vous dit qu'il faut
savoir rebondir personne vous dites ça
fait ça ce que je veux vous dire c'est
c'est vous qui décidez monsieur moi dit
ça va aller il va se précipiter à la
mairie pour s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales on a bien compris
je vous invite d'aller manger
gratuitement
bon appétit et merci à vous à travers
des supports comme les élections et bien
ils vont dévier inconsciemment ou
consciemment sur leur crainte de la
prélipide en tant qu'homme je comprends
et je peux comprendre leur colère mais
je suis aussi un éducateur et ce rôle
d'éducateur je me dois aussi de leur
dire attention la vie de demain ça sera
ça ça et ça voilà tout simplement c'est
une réalité que le monde dans lequel ils
vont évoluer ils évoluent déjà est
extrêmement difficile pour les jeunes
oui oui elle est difficile parce que
diplôme ils ont absolument rien et
d'ailleurs c'est la caractéristique de
l'épître c'est à dire qu'on prend des
jeunes justement les pides c'est la
force de cet établissement c'est que
l'on prend des des jeunes qui ont on va
dire rien tout simplement
et il faut qu'on les met dans le circuit
du mont du travail vous voyez on parle
de très très très loin
[Musique]
17h30 l'école est finie pour aujourd'hui
comme dans n'importe quel cours de
récréation les jeunes s'amusent et
décompresse
[Applaudissements]
c'est tous les soirs comme ça
la famille
[Musique]
préoccupé son père un militaire
lui a déjà passé 6 mois ici dans huit
semaines son contrat prendra fin ses
camarades ont déjà trouvé un emploi
elles ont quitté le centre
ah vous êtes toute seule là oui et
profitez-en c'est génial
c'était quoi les blablas du soir
tout ce qui se passe on parle de tout et
de rien des potages de pis puis on se
parle c'est sympa ça fait mieux que de
tout ça
pas trop il faut savoir vivre tout seul
aussi
à tout et plus on rigole en fait donc en
quoi vous avez changé depuis que vous
êtes là bon
j'ai pris un peu confiance en moi
j'étais un peu timide réservé
ouais c'est vrai que
parler comme ça
c'est pas des choses que j'ai l'habitude
de faire j'aimais bien écouter les
conneries des autres et puis maintenant
j'aime bien dire
pour réussir à dire des bêtises et ça je
suis pas sûr qu'il faut être content
est-ce que ça a pas été trop dur de de
s'éloigner de ses parents vous êtes
jeune encore
moi j'ai trouvé que
ça coupait un peu le cordon en fait
on sent plus grand on sent moins le
petit bébé a son papa on sent vraiment
grandir là je crois qu'il y a foot il y
a la cantine
le régime d'internat ne coupe pas
seulement le cordon avec la famille il
permet aussi de tenir à distance les
mauvaises fréquentations du quartier
tous les volontaires sans exception
vivent donc à l'internat du lundi au
vendredi le week-end il rentre chez leur
parents pour les moins chanceux
l'établissement dispose d'un appartement
en ville
il est 21h30 extinction des feux dans
deux heures
c'est facile le coucher où ils sont un
peu
excité mais en règle générale ça va
surtout l'hiver parce qu'il fait froid
par contre l'été effectivement il fait
chaud il fait encore jour à cette heure
là donc c'est un petit peu un petit peu
plus compliqué mais
généralement les obser quand même assez
facilement
et quand on quand ses enfants
ils sont grands mais je les vois petit
non mais c'est vrai ils sont grands mais
je les vois on sent que
on sent que ça pousse mais que c'est pas
encore
à peine tout juste donc ce ne sont pas
des enfants ce sont de jeunes adultes
voilà ils arrivent à faire confiance ils
arrivent à se donner facilement
ils sont pas hyper prudents justement
parce qu'ils ont déjà beaucoup morflé
non bah non parce que je pense qu'ils
partent aussi du principe que ici ils se
soutiennent justement beaucoup parce
qu'ils ont pas tous le même passé mais
au moins un vécu un peu similaire avec
des carences un peu similaires aussi et
donc du coup ils se comprennent bien par
rapport à ça je pense
ils sont pas rentrés encore là non mais
là ils vont rentrer et puis il y a les
collègues de la nuit là qui viennent
d'arriver je retrouve Laurent l'ancien
légionnaire il va assurer la permanence
jusqu'à cette heure en principe les
nuits sont calmes
donc là vous allez faire un tour des
chambres pas dans l'immé
où ils sont ils ont encore un peu de
temps pour dialoguer entre eux la seule
chose oui à laquelle on doit prêter
attention c'est plus de circulation à
partir de 22h là sur les terrasses ça
pour ça il y a des soirs c'est un peu
compliqué parce qu'ils essayent
de ce que j'ai pu constater depuis
combien oui monsieur
c'est des jeunes voilà c'est avec tout
ce que ça peut engendrer ça peut être
calme un soir ça peut être un peu plus
énervé le lendemain mais ouais dans
l'ensemble ils sont relativement calme
ils seront relativement calme
contrairement à ce qu'on aurait pu
penser le fait qu'il vienne de quartier
pas forcément super etc ils sont plutôt
ils sont plutôt cool ils sont plutôt
cool
là je vais aller voir ce qui se passe là
parce que ouais
les histoires comme ça à 22h30 enfin 20
à 22h je crois pas trop mais il faut un
bon pourquoi pas
d'accord
posez posez-vous posez-vous non mais
tranquille détendez-vous détendez-vous
de la galette là c'est bon on discute
par contre vous le savez vous le savez
on est en internat
même si vous absentez de la Chambre ne
serait-ce que 2 minutes pour aller à la
laverie récupérer votre linge ou quoi ne
laissez pas
vous laisser la chance
pourquoi il y a des gens qui ont des
choses il y a des chevaux parce que
les gens à la fois
qui n'aura pas ce que vous vous avez et
qui essaiera de vous le taxer Laurent
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
et ben apparemment jeune femme serait
fait piquer elle serait fait pitié un
téléphone
qui vient d'acheter qui est encore
emballé
sorties que les jeunes essayent de
s'escomper on en a pas donc c'est
vraiment très rare que les vols les vols
c'est récurrent on regarde dans les
chambres si effectivement il y en a pas
un qui détendent
mais une belle surprise
de me le dire
c'est pas un coup de boulon parce que ça
c'est un truc pour couple c'est un
taille-haie mais bon il a pas avoir ça
dans sa chambre le jeune c'est pas
franchement une bonne idée
branches je sais pas faire des trucs je
sais même pas pourquoi il a ça dans sa
chambre
systématiquement quand il rentre on
fouille leurs sac parce que ils peuvent
revenir à la maison se faire confier
quelque chose par un copain qui veut
faire passer un autre etc etc notamment
pour tout ce qui est stupéfiant ou
alcool étant donné que ces deux de
produits qui sont formellement interdits
ici donc on fait très attention
là-dessus maintenant voilà on n'est pas
à l'abri tu ramènes un
j'ai jamais vu ça j'ai jamais vu ça mec
il arrive à passer avec un truc quand
même un bordel qui fait quand même près
d'un mètre quoi mais ça ça mérite une
sanction importante non
alors ça ça va être notifié on en fera
un compte rendu par mail là tout de
suite au référent section qui va qui va
gérer la sauce voilà
pendant ce temps là la fouille des
chambres continue je suis fatigué
vous êtes au courant quand même
allez merci monsieur
vous nous donnez en arrivant au centre
on le met dans le coffre-fort vous le
récupérez à votre sortie comme ça au
moins vous êtes sûrs
finalement les moniteurs ne retrouveront
ni le portable ni l'argent il rédigeront
deux rapports un pour la cisaille
l'autre pour le téléphone
il n'y aura pas d'autres incidence cette
nuit là
[Musique]
je peux rentrer c'est bon à côté les
gars poubelle et les vider tout trois
fois je leur ai dit de vider la poubelle
la poubelle elle est là mettez de
l'entrain un peu là
un élève est-ce que ça a pas ça risque
pas de le braquer l'objectif en fait du
conseil de discipline c'est de le faire
réagir je comprends que c'est vachement
compliqué là pour vous vous étiez à
limite à deux doigts de partir là
c'est normal franchement on est pas bien
6h30 l'internat s'éveille
madame pérenge peut rentrer petit
déjeuner dans une demi-heure personne ne
doit être en retard
bonjour bonjour
ça vous me ranger ça aussi s'il vous
plaît
cette salle qui traîne
c'est madame terrange je peux rentrer
comment ça monsieur Sané c'est bon à
côté les gars poubelle et les vider tout
c'est surtout l'hygiène donc voir qu'ils
ont fait leur lit vider la poubelle pour
éviter que ça traîne pendant des jours
et des jours et puis voilà l'état des
toilettes voilà et tout ça faut que ce
soit fait avancer parce qu'après il y a
le petit déjeuner il faut limiter les
retards au petit-déjeuner sinon après
ils sont en tugue
travaux d'utilité générale donc c'est le
mercredi après-midi il s'occupe de la
propreté du centre
ça va bon bah comme d'hab
elles sont déjà parties au petit
déjeuner je vais quand même vérifier la
chambre
ah non
c'est Kim zelbari
qu'est-ce que vous faites encore
c'est la première panne de réveil de
Leslie pourtant elle n'échappera pas la
sanction pas de petit déjeuner allez on
fait le lit on se lève on s'active
monsieur de Maria Monsieur Saïd ou
monsieur Hassani trois fois je leur ai
dit de vider la poubelle la poubelle
elle est là vous avez de la chance que
je la pas par terre
ments plus encore qu'à l'école la
pédagogie est affaire de répétitions
trois fois je vous ai demandé quoi
passer un coup dans la salle de bain
vider la poubelle
oui ou non
[Musique]
revoilà Leslie malgré sa panne
d'oreiller ce matin et son retard elle
négocie son petit déjeuner avec Chloé
c'est dur je sais que c'est dur mais bon
allez allez voir s'il y a pas moyen de
prendre un café mais je pense ça va être
compliqué
Jean-Pierre il m'a dit de demander à
vous allez voir au moins un café
ok la champion normalement c'est pas le
petit déj parce que quand vous êtes en
retard au travail et ben vous vous
dépêchez vous partez au travail
généralement vous souhaitez le petit déj
donc voilà puis ça les oblige aussi à se
responsabiliser
c'est tout l'enjeu ici
faire comprendre doucement mais
fermement à ces jeunes que dans le monde
des adultes leurs actes auront des
conséquences ça nous entraîne sur le
travail plus tard qu'on fait la grasse
mat on aura notre travail en fait donc
bah c'est bien ça nous permet de prendre
un bon rythme de vie en fait
Leslie a quand même eu droit à un petit
café mais elle n'échappera pas aux
travaux d'utilité générale vider cette
poubelle là vider le cendrier qui est là
dans la poubelle j'étais la poubelle et
puis bah ramasser les mégots qui
traînent zelbari OK
[Musique]
chez les garçons on ramasse on est suit
on balaie mais là encore la propreté
n'est pas l'enjeu c'est plutôt pour
apprendre à avoir une vie de grand quoi
avoir un travail être propre savoir se
lever à l'heure les bases monsieur Gomez
Erickson de son prénom à 22 ans il a
rejoint sa mère en France à l'âge de 16
ans son père et ses frères sont restés
en Guinée-Bissau parlant mal notre
langue jamais scolarisée sans aucune
qualification il a traîné cinq ans dans
la rue ses débuts dans le centre ont été
difficiles au début c'était un peu un
peu la galère j'ai eu pas mal de fiches
événements
des insultes ça c'est ça sortait souvent
au quartier c'était ça
c'était un peu comme la jungle quoi
tout ça c'est du passé maintenant chez
je sais ce que je veux
Ericson cherche un emploi dans la grande
distribution et pourquoi pas un jour
avoir son propre magasin
ce matin Laurent est en forme les
corvées sont rondement menés
[Musique]
c'est des consignes c'est des repères et
c'est constamment tous les jours le
répéter les mêmes consignes de manière à
ce qui les intègre et qui puisse agir
d'eux-mêmes
on essaie de les amener vers à être
autonome c'est tout simplement voilà
c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont perdu à
un moment il faut
nous le but la mission c'est leur donner
le goût quoi il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
aient envie quoi
les prothèses
après 10 ans de légion Laurent n'a aucun
mal à donner de la voix mettez de
l'entrain un peu là
encadrer des jeunes au quotidien c'est
assez sympa ça permet de rester jeune ça
donne bien la patate et surtout ça donne
ça donne envie on a envie nous quelque
part on a fait des choix de vie qui nous
ont plutôt bien réussi donc on a envie
aussi que ces jeunes ils aient aussi
envie et qui prennent du plaisir à faire
ce qu'ils font tous les jours et qu'ils
avancent
ici il a retrouvé une famille près d'un
encadrant sur deux est un ancien
militaire
pour l'ensemble avant commandement
jeunes intègrent ce centre chaque année
la plupart s'adapte rapidement au cadre
mais il faut parfois rappeler les règles
avec autorité conseil disciplines ce
matin c'est pour traiter de choses c'est
pas la première fois qu'il a quelques
soucis de discipline ce garçon
le jeu n'aurait trahi une camarade en
divulguant un secret qu'elle lui avait
confié
pour la direction c'est une faute grave
capacité cognitive mais fait preuve par
Fun stade immaturité je crois que c'est
ça son problème hein
c'est un jeune homme qui travaille bien
certes il manque de maturité mais quand
même c'est un garçon qui est vraiment
bien à qui on peut parler
pas grand chose à rectifier pour qu'il
soit qu'il soit bien on le fait rentrer
s'il vous plaît vous pouvez m'expliquer
les raisons pour lesquelles vous êtes
allé raconter à tout le monde ce que
vous avez confié dans le camarade de ma
chambre m'a posé des questions il
voulait savoir des choses j'ai juste
répondu aux questions
confidentiel on garde ça pour soi
mademoiselle qui est là pour le défendre
allez dites-moi donc moi j'ai parlé avec
lui et il m'a demandé mademoiselle elle
a insulté aussi il y a pas que lui
d'accord
autre chose
moi je m'entends super bien avec lui
j'ai vu que enfin avec les autres aussi
ils sont tombés avec tout le monde et
c'est vrai que c'est un peu trop vite
votre projet professionnel
dites-moi où vous en êtes je fais le CV
et la lettre de motivation je l'ai fait
à moitié à moitié oui
de motivation c'est une page
donc c'est 10 lignes donc
un petit effort pour le 5 suivantes
très bien donc vous sortez mademoiselle
aussi vous revenez seul
à un élève est-ce que ça a pas ça risque
pas de le braquer ça risque pas de le
s'il a il se repositionne pas très vite
avec un adoptant une autre posture etc
les deux trois dernières mouilles qu'il
lui reste il va continuer à attendre que
ça passe on va arriver à la fin de son
contrat il se sera rien passé donc là
l'objectif en fait du conseil de
discipline c'est de le faire réagir et
qu'il y aille voilà donc c'est pour ça
un moment donné c'est forcément
pédagogique voilà c'est pas sanctionner
pour sanctionner il faut que la sanction
signifie quelque chose
le Conseil discipline a estimé que la
faute était grave je pense pas que cela
vous surprenne et donc décidé de vous
exclure deux semaines
bon
quoi c'est vous qui avez les cartes en
main c'est pas nous allez en avant bonne
journée
l'exclusion est immédiate mais hors de
question de rester les bras croisés
pendant deux semaines l'élève devra
terminer sa lettre de motivation et
peaufiner son projet professionnel
[Musique]
c'est sa dernière opportunité avant
l'expulsion définitive
[Musique]
à la sortie du conseil je retrouve le
directeur du Centre
donc donc c'est un peu l'école de la
deuxième chance on peut dire ça ou c'est
une image
il est temps de faire quelque chose
vous donne une deuxième chance et que il
faut pas se rater c'est comme ça qu'il
le comprennent absolument
pour un élève le séjour est totalement
gratuit mais il coûte 30 000 euros à
l'état alors ici on ne retient pas ce
qui manque de motivation
dans ces écoles d'insertion
professionnelle on apprend aussi à être
solidaire cet après-midi la section de
Marina Ericsson va donner un coup de
main au Secours populaire de mes yeux
cette activité les jeunes en raffole ils
se sont tous portés volontaires pour
remettre à neuf cette maison
Ericsson ne quitte plus son téléphone la
directrice d'un supermarché doit
l'appeler un poste de magazine est en
jeu
pour me dire que c'est bon ce sera
il faut croiser les doigts
en attendant
Erics
ça touche beaucoup en fait
aider les exclus ça touche ces jeunes
mais ça les angoisse aussi c'est
tellement dur maintenant que que on a
tous envie de se donner les moyens de
travailler et tout et on a tous peur au
fond même ceux qui ont du travail de se
retrouver à la rue de patron ils sont
ils sont durs quoi ils ne laissent pas
de chance en fait même il demande de
l'expérience et quand on sort de l'école
des fois on n'a pas d'expérience moment
de détente méritée pour les jeunes en
compagnie de Daniel et Chloé les deux
moniteurs
Ericsson lui ne tient plus il décide
d'appeler la directrice du supermarché
malheureusement le job ne sera pas pour
lui
c'est un coup dur pour Ericsson il était
convaincu d'en avoir fini avec les pides
d'être sorti d'affaires c'est pas grave
elle me rappelle elle m'a pas appelé et
je vais appeler je l'ai appelé et elle
m'a dit ça
un peu je comprends que ça vous ça vous
embête un petit peu là Monsieur Gomez
à deux doigts de partir là on s'est un
peu enflammé aussi mais c'est pas fini
on a envoyé beaucoup beaucoup de lettres
de motivation NCV monsieur Gomez
regardez Intermarché là quand est-ce
qu'il vous ont appelé aujourd'hui hier
et voilà donc vous voyez ça commence à
redescendre petit à petit
faut pas non faut pas vous démotiver là
je vous ai vu avec la banane pendant 48
heures faut garder la même motivation on
y retourne c'est pas terminé vous savez
combien de cv lettre de motivation j'ai
envoyé moi pour être pour être embauché
finalement à l'Épide 250
et au bout d'un moment voilà moi aussi
je me disais je sers à rien machin truc
et finalement j'ai trouvé l'épi et je
m'éclate maintenant faut tout optimiser
faut voir le positif ça bon dia ok allez
on tourne la page c'est terminé on se
projette on passe sur autre chose on se
retrouve les manches et on y retourne
[Musique]
c'est une sorte d'injustice pour eux
c'est voilà ça leur renvoie je vous dis
à leur passé à leurs échecs c'est un de
plus quoi donc ils ont l'impression que
grâce à l'Épide ils vont réussir et puis
finalement
l'échec existe toujours quoi voilà mais
il existera jusqu'à la fin de la vie et
c'est aussi le but de l'épître de leur
apprendre à rebondir quoi
retour à l'internat les jeunes qui
m'entourent n'ont pas 20 ans et à cet
âge-là on ne pense pas seulement à
trouver du travail
quand on fréquente des hommes et des
filles et des garçons comme ça toute la
journée il y a des il y a des amourettes
un peu qui se créent ici
il y a beaucoup de garde
bonjour monsieur la question était
est-ce que vous avez une petite fiancée
ici oui vous avez rencontré ici donc et
c'est facile d'avoir une histoire
d'amour à l'huile
ça parle beaucoup
[Musique]
les gens ils sont à l'affût les cadres
ils sont au courant
[Musique]
j'ai placé
allez on y va
le sport joue un rôle important
les internes ont deux heures d'activité
physique par jour
en même temps dans l'eau on évite de
faire trop de vagues pour embêter les
gens qui viennent qui viennent nager
parmi vous il y en a certains qui ne
sont pas très à l'aise dans l'eau donc
je vous demande pareil de faire très
attention à eux
tranquille quoi
l'atelier piscine est sous la
responsabilité de Cédric avant Lépide il
allait sauver des gens aux quatre coins
du monde il faisait des rapatriements
sanitaires
aujourd'hui il aide les jeunes à garder
la tête hors de l'eau
dans l'eau il faut rien vous arriver
à 10 minutes sous le je viens
ouais
super
son arrière là il a plongé
[Musique]
j'ai peur monsieur
vous êtes capable de le faire
j'ai pas vu
il était génial il était génial
franchement il faut faire comme ça c'est
génial allez la tête on souffle dans
l'eau on fait des bulles dans l'autre ça
leur permet mais après d'être plus
confiant quand il recherche un emploi
quand ils font des démarches quand ils
quand ils sont au travail etc c'est
vraiment que eux prennent conscience de
leurs limites et qui n'arrive petit à
petit à surmonter leur difficulté et
vous votre rôle dans l'histoire c'est
quoi les rassurer tous les rassurés rien
de plus passer un super bon avec eux
parce que c'est vrai que c'est agréable
ils sont super sympas ils sont
volontaires ils ont envie d'avancer donc
pour nous c'est vraiment super motivant
je ne suis pas prof de sport je suis
référent je suis éducateur mais je veux
les je veux les accompagner je veux les
aider justement à surmonter ces épreuves
et tous ensemble on est plus fort pour
les surmonter les épreuves
Ericsson semble avoir digéré la mauvaise
nouvelle de la journée après tout des
supermarchés il y en a beaucoup d'autres
ça remonte le moral
sinon aujourd'hui j'allais rester dans
mon lit hein c'est ce que je voulais
faire sur le plus envie de
d'en faire quoi j'en veux plus envie de
rien il est resté
la piscine tranquille
[Musique]
dernier cours
il nageait
finalement moi j'ai appris
franchement les plongeons
salut Benji ça va
comment ça s'est passé
j'ai vécu une expérience vraiment
intéressante et même touchante parce que
tous ces jeunes qu'on a pu côtoyer sont
vraiment vraiment attachants
ici
il grandissent ils nous l'ont tous dit
et c'est vraiment poignant même de voir
à quel point ils font des efforts pour
pour réussir à s'en sortir et il faut
juste maintenant espérer que le marché
du travail fasse enfin une place assez
jeune qui ont besoin d'un peu plus de
temps que les autres bah écoute bonne
immersion à toi parce que je crois que
c'est ton tour
que je pars bientôt là promis je
prendrai des nouvelles allez je
t'embrasse salut
s'il vous plaît monsieur
mon immersion s'achève comme elle a
commencé devant le drapeau le vendredi
le directeur récompense publiquement les
élèves qui se sont distingués pour ces
jeunes qui n'ont souvent connu que
l'échec ce rituel est très important il
n'y a pas de petit progrès tout avancé
est appelé
le code
monsieur du Cap
c'est très bien monsieur
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais également dire un petit mot
sur la section de Monsieur Rodriguez qui
a participé à une distribution de
denrées alimentaires j'aurais félicité
monsieur Sané mademoiselle kandins
[Applaudissements]
c'est une démarche tout à fait louable
et donc je vous en félicite
de ce centre avec une formation ou un
emploi ici on appelle ça une sortie
positive moi j'y verrai plutôt un pied
de nez au fait Alice ambiant preuve que
quand la République donne une deuxième
chance à des jeunes déterminés tout
n'est pas perdu
[Musique]